[Music]
it seems the one thing Democrats are
happy about with the Helsinki summit is
that it keeps the heat off the Muller
probe a CNN headlined today blared Trump
team worries could Helsinki disaster
strengthen Muller's hand speaking of the
Muller probe there are more allegations
of unfair treatment there are reports
the Democratic lobbyist Tony Podesta
worked on behalf of a Ukrainian interest
without registering under the foreign
agent Registration Act Muller indicted
Trump's former campaign manager Paul
Manafort over very similar accusations
so our mana fort and Podesta being
treated the same by Muller steam not
according to Tucker Carlson's reporting
last night we can report exclusively
based on two separate sources we spoke
to today the Tony Podesta has been
offered immunity by robert muller to
testify against Paul Manafort in other
words for a near identical crime bill
and Hilary's friend could skate and
emerge completely unscathed
while Paul Manafort may rot in jail that
doesn't seem very fair here to discuss
his former FBI spokesperson John Ian
ireli retired FBI special agent Bobby
Chacon and Democratic strategist Scott
Bolden who's joining me here in the in
office in the studio I should say Bobby
I want to ask you you being involved in
engaging in the FBI when do you use
immunity and you know why is it that we
continue to see if the reporting is true
I have every reason to believe Tucker
Carlson in the Hillary Clinton probe
they gave out five sets of humidity and
got nothing for it and now here we're
hearing reports that Tony Podesta is
getting immunity when do you use it when
is it appropriate well there's a couple
of reasons really the first and foremost
one is you would think it might be is if
the person you're dealing with has
committed a crime if they haven't
committed a crime or you don't think
they've committed a crime they have
nothing to be immune from so clearly
Podesta is thought of by the Muller team
to have engaged in some kind of conduct
that he needs immunity from that's the
first and foremost thing the second
thing is you feel that he has some
information that he could give you on
some of the people that are target's
from you
in your investigation which on't which
means only that he must have dealt with
them either in a criminal conspiracy or
in criminal matters that relate to
molars investigation so there's two
things they must think the Podesta did
something illegal and that that illegal
activity or some activity that he
engaged in was connected to the probe
going on because that's how criminal
conspiracies work guys get together to
commit crimes so so Podesta really this
immunity deal to me puts Podesta right
in the middle of this thing
Scott how do you react to this when we
see this report and suddenly they're
handing out immunity to yet another
Democrat well this isn't a partisan
issue I'm a former prosecutor I'm a
white-collar criminal defense lawyer so
my colleague on your program is
absolutely right but every case is
different here's the deal
metaphor certainly has more critics
charged with more crimes substantially
more than Podesta and if desta was part
of a deal or some type of conspiracy
then he has information that they need
to prosecute manna for others to they
they believe he's committed a crime he
was a subject or a target and three
Madoff was fighting these charges Manta
Ford isn't rolling over and trying to
cooperate and make America better and
tell what's going on with Russia and
Trump and others he's fighting these
charges that's why he's in jail and
that's why Podesta is getting immunity
John
you you beat your background with the
FBI you saw what happened in the Hillary
Clinton probe but then you know five
sets of immunity and the FBI omitted we
got nothing for that in exchange have
you ever seen that if the FBI ever have
any other case where they handed out
five sets of immunity got nothing for it
and now here they are handing out
immunity again well they're kidding I'm
sorry they're getting they're getting
his testimony in the prosecution of
metaphor that's something that's super
valuable for any prosecutor yeah but I
John you you were had a long career at
the FBI how did you see this handout so
many immunities is unusual and to get
nothing for it I think the lesson we're
seeing here is if you're going to commit
a crime it pays to have a relative who's
in high political office so that you can
be the one to offered immunity but let's
not forget the reality is that maybe he
knows something that the
other people being charged don't know
maybe he can offer more information
they're obviously going to look for
getting the biggest bang for their buck
yeah and I have a hard time believing
that that going after Mr Man afford is
the biggest fish I mean was with the
Trump campaign for like what three or
four months something like that but
we'll see I mean Muller has been given a
lot of latitude but I don't they're
trying to equate what happened in Russia
with mr. Putin and this but there's been
no evidence of any collusion I want to
go and talk actually about some of the
something else something that was in a
little bit more of the fallout from the
Helsinki summit former intelligence
chiefs are now politicizing their role
in going after Trump and here's what
former acting a former acting CIA
director said at what point will there
be critical mass of objection to some of
the lunacy that's going on here under
this president to state at baldly
the United States was attacked and the
president sided with the enemy a now
stood FBI director James Comey had to
throw in his two cents tweeting quote
all who believe in this country's values
must vote for Democrats this fall policy
differences don't matter right now
history has its eyes on us gentlemen is
this an appropriate thing for the former
Intel Chiefs that to jump in here do
this and I actually want to start with
Scott because I think these things
actually play into Donald Trump's hands
well what is I don't think they plan in
the hand but what is your issue with
what they've said your GOP colleagues
have said what Democrats have said and
what we watched we watched a president
that did not denounce Russia thirteen of
his government agency agents were were
just indicted by Muller they have had we
have 78 administration okay and 17
agencies have said that they attacked
our election system and and our
president GOP president denies it and
then he gets on a consequential were she
gave nothing about it it's too strong to
say he denies it he said he misspoke you
know that Donna spoke you know that
Donald Trump does not like to go on and
correct
Missy and he went back out there and he
you know he doesn't like to do though he
doesn't but I gotta tell you saying
misspoke when he when you're under that
summit should never have taken place
with these indictments and with those
seven I never should see anybody John
John I wonder if I gotta bring in John
here John you've got a lot of experience
as an FBI agent is it the right proper
place for these Intel chiefs to be able
to go out right after and then go start
to say and advocate for the Democrats
how does that play hey I'll tell you I
am just happy that Comey is using his
personal phone and not a government
phone if he's tweeting but they should
have been doing this the reality is that
they understand from those positions a
lot of moving parts are going on behind
the scenes nobody actually knows once
you're out of position what the
president is doing or his administration
so they actually could be undermining
other factors that there are taking
place and I will tell you whether you
like Putin don't like Putin like Trump
don't like Trump it never hurts to speak
to the other side because every time you
do you get a little more television let
me go to Bobby here Bobby your
experience and FBI director or former
Intel Chiefs that are out there making
these comments how does that strike you
it's it's irresponsible and it actually
damages the Republic I would be in favor
of certain senior level policy officials
being barred from doing this kind of
political rhetoric I mean we have the
Hatch Act which which has is enforceable
against government employees but once
you leave the government there should be
some enforceable mechanism that these
guys cannot go out it the senior policy
guys who had access to all this
information and then go on these tweet
storms and pretty much some of them lost
their mind in their anger and rhetoric
against the current president and I
think that you can't separate that
rhetoric from some of the things that
they knew and learned with their
security clearances and their prior jobs
so I think there has to be some kind of
cooling-off period where these guys have
to keep their mouth shut
go home and sit on their hands and watch
the government function because right
now they're interfering with the
function of our government as former
senior policy executives so they lose
their First Amendment right that's
really what he's saying here's the
huston bottom line the Hatch Act the
Hatch Act is perfectly enforceable under
political speech for twenty Act was
enforceable against me for 27 years the
First Amendment does it doesn't get
enforceable when you're employed or not
employed the First Amendment of
Constitution does not spell out that it
can only be enforceable when you're
employed or not employed there are
certain government employment that can
be enforced let me give Scott a sec
here's the bottom line though yes Donald
Trump drives every narrative in this
presidency right you want to block
people from observing and speaking on
what they saw then both sides were
highly critical of right how about no I
didn't wait wait a sec I didn't suggest
that they block it what I'm saying is it
plays into Donald Trump's hands because
what he says is I didn't get a fair
shake these people were conspiring
against me and then you have James Comey
months after saying he's got a higher
loyalty saying don't worry about the
policy policies don't matter in this
country and just vote for Democrats
which is in his self-interest because he
doesn't want a probe of himself but wait
a minute now the GOP is in control and
the GOP left him he didn't leave the GOP
he was a lifelong Republican huh sure it
isn't independent but what I'm saying is
when he goes out and says vote for
Democrats no matter what what is his
best interest if the Democrats take over
the house then these probes that Devin
Nunez and trey gowdy and John Radcliffe
and everybody do that goes away and I
hope America sees through the what he's
trying to do it away with gop-controlled
then you all control everything so why
hasn't it gone away then why won't do
Jay turn over documents to the GOP on it
that's a whole nother cue and I will
agree on John I want to give you the
last word here we've got just like ten
seconds what does the average FBI agent
out there the rank-and-file when they
what do they think when they see a
person like James Comey go out and say
vote for Democrats hey can we just get
back to being agents and doing our jobs
without all the political discussion
that's what the rank-and-file agents are
thinking we don't want our directors to
be political we want to be able to have
the public's trust and do the job that
they're doing right now yeah and you're
right my grandfather was a career FBI
agent I can't thank those men and women
enough for what they do and how they do
it
gentlemen I want to say thank you